I know so many normies politically
uninitiated people who believe the
stupidest craziest insane stuff ever
it's blue and on it's blue enough oh I
love that phrase me too it is but like
they're screaming that Donald Trump
staged an Insurrection and like you know
I'm just like I know but like what what
about when like the feminist Storm Into
the the Senate and you know
Congressional buildings like three times
remember that text protecting them
though did you see Urban Dictionary took
uh blue and on out they put it back they
did put it back but they did they took
it down so this is the craziest thing
urban dictionary which is supposed to be
where you Define colloquial terms used
in you know modern settings deleted blue
Anon because blueanon was basically
saying it is a reference to Democrat
voters and individuals who believe on
hinged conspiracies about Russian
collusion and that mobs and militias are
going to storm the capital at any moment
and they need razor wire and so Urban
Dictionary took it down there's that's
not it's it's not it's not hate speech
it's not uh uh disparaging anybody based
on race or gender identity they took it
down because it's always been political
so it's politics I thought Urban
Dictionary was like where normal people
would go and kind of crowdsource the
meaning of these up-and-coming you know
the kids these days are using these
words like heat or whatever I don't know
what kids are saying these days but I
was like
hello seriously you don't know what is
it 533 is that ye yeah yeah yeah it's
like to throw something yeah yeah it's
like to get rid of it yeah you know I
know unfortunately there's another word
and you know all these these these
dangle kids they use the skull emoji for
laughing instead of the like I'm dead
yeah yeah
literally dead literally I do a whole
show on Urban Dictionary nonsense yeah
yeah but there was a point where Urban
Dictionary started Banning words that
were offensive
uh I don't know huh I mean look at look
at Miriam I think it was Miriam Webster
that changed what we talked about this
before they changed the definition of
gender to create a paradoxical Loop oh
yeah yes they put gender in the
definition right they put the word
gender in the definition of gender so
it's like not becomes a paradox do you
remember when Maisie I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry it becomes an incur
a cursive a recursive Loop
recursion recursion yeah I think so yeah
recursive Loop yeah do you remember what
Maisie hirono was saying that saying the
word sexual orientation were offensive
and Merriam-Webster went in and changed
it so that this was obviously a
pejorative it never been before this is
the this so this is how it works man
there are a lot of people who need to
wake the f up
so we had we had Clifton Duncan on the
show the other day right he was like uh
he says Broadway veteran classically
trained actor everybody apparently loved
the sound of his voice oh me too oh yeah
and he was talking about how
he's like a liberal guy and he's still
very liberal on policy but he's like
watching all this go down and most
people agree with him and he's like I
gotta say something and speak up and
like now here he is on the show talking
about what's going on in his industry
and what he's experiencing but there are
a lot of people who don't pay attention
and they hear in the news some insane
thing like did you hear that Amy Coney
Barrett said some like like homophobic
thing at the at the trial whoa or at the
confirmation what did she say I don't
know I was like apparently that caused a
huge like uproar like I can't believe
she said what she said and then also you
have all these normies who don't pay
attention just thinking she said
something when she literally didn't what
do you what do you guys think is the
best way to Red Pill people like that I
don't like the phrase red pill yeah it's
kind of vague and it kind of insinuates
it's abrupt like because in Neo when he
takes the red pill he's like shocked
into reality but I don't I don't want to
uh necessarily entertain the concept
that one tribe has all the answers
necessarily yeah like when they say you
know red pills I I say like sure but the
people who use the fries red pill aren't
always right and I don't want to be a
tribal thing where you go to someone who
might not agree with conservatives like
like Clifton clearly was not
conservative and so his world view is
very very different from people who are
conservative who are more likely to use
those phrases however that being said if
we're into the fair assessment and
definition of what red pill is I think
Michael malice's definition what does he
basically say when white pilling no no
red pill Michael Mouse's definition of
red pilling is that when you realize The
Narrative of the corporate press yeah is
you know it's like the cathedral is
wrong they're right yeah they're lying
to you corporate press so it's all about
it's all about looking past the
corporate press it's it's it's
remarkable when I have a conversation
with someone and they're like look man
you know all these people rioting and
protesting yeah but Trump staged an
Insurrection and I'm like they were
banging on the doors of the Supreme
Court building when Kavanaugh was there
they changed the definitions in
dictionaries to smear the Supreme Court
justices they don't like they the women
in the pink hats literally stormed into
the Congressional buildings occupying
every floor Congress shut down when was
that yeah that was the day of the
Kavanaugh hearing 2018 yeah yeah I
filmed the left storming Congress a
bunch of that happens all the time
certainly I mean I was talking to one of
my friends who's a officer in DC and he
was like man it was bad it was bad and I
was like yeah but this happens all the
time like how many times have I filmed
them storming the Capitol Building like
I lost my press pass because I was
filming people storming the Capitol
Building wow but that's not that I was
with them that's why it's crazy that
Ashley Babbitt was shot yeah and right
now now I guess her representative her
family and their representation is
saying
there was no threat to the that guy on
the other side of the door no one had
breached the door she was standing up to
look through the window and he was not
threatened with anything she was not
flashing I think he just saw her face
not only that there were cops apparently
below that allowed those people to go up
the stairs wow and I don't know I don't
know how true that is but I do know in
the video you watch the cops like walk
up right after she got shot they're
there they were literally there
so it's remarkable that you can have all
these women storm into which building
was it it was like it was all of them I
think it was I know it was I filmed it
in heart right right and they're like on
every floor there was a bunch of
buildings yeah and they shot didn't it
shut down Congress yeah I believe so
they don't call it an insurrection they
didn't say it was an Insurrection they
say it was well they were fighting for
women's rights didn't they allowed
didn't they get into the elevator with
congressmen and scream at them in their
faces would that be considered and those
elevators are for congress members
it's wild it's making me think about the
corporate press and the whole don't
question the vote and it's all like
don't question the vote it's not don't
question the vote online because we'll
ban your account don't question the vote
at the Capitol because hold on don't
even show Donald Trump speaking at CPAC
don't quote him saying it they banned
RSB they suspended rsbn for two weeks
and gave them a strike for simply
showing Donald Trump speaking that's
insane Ford Fisher journalist he he his
footage of Donald Trump speaking on
January 6 was used by a bunch of news
outlets because he licenses it out they
banned him they they apparently like
suspended not bama they suspended his
channel give him a strike meanwhile the
New York Times other outlets use the
exact same footage so I think what we're
seeing is it's it's not so much about
the rules are meaningless what it really
is
they're waiting they're sitting there
saying we only want corporate
establishment press we want the
cathedral's narrative to be the only
narrative
however they need an excuse to ban
people
they there was a lot of there are a lot
of problems when they started randomly
Banning people and it led to huge press
cycles of like why was this person
banned and they didn't break any rules
then you get people all tweeting like
crazy we demand you reinstate them and
then they're pressured into reinstating
people
but when you see someone get banned and
then they say you posted a video that
broke this rule it's definitive I'll
tell you this I've had people hit me up
and they're like yo Tim my channel got
shut down I don't know why can you help
me out and I'm like for sure what
happened I said this video got taken
down and now I can't upload and then I
look at the video and I'm like
you you showed that news story
like if if I send this to Google and say
hey this is incorrect they're going to
say no it's not we said you can't show
that news story
it's probably bunk
it's probably a BS reason but it's like
what you know what real argument do you
have for like a big boycott or a big
push when
they they broke the rule so certainly we
still push back and say that shouldn't
be a rule you should be allowed to
express your opinion and say what you
want to say but from a technical
standpoint you end up with some
low-level Google employee that like I
might be able to email or have access to
and they're going to be like I just
can't override my boss the rules are the
rules we told everybody in January you
can't say these things or show these
things in any context so now Donald
Trump's speeches are being removed
ultimately I think it's going to be
really really good for Trump
I think it's going to be really good for
Trump I mean look what happened at Dr
Seuss books they banned him and now
they're like thousands of dollars yeah
wow yeah so like like people the more
you ban something the more people want
to hear it but I think it's gonna be
that way I think with Trump one of the
biggest problems he had was that he
couldn't keep his mouth shut it
benefited him a lot of ways his ability
to control the narrative and bypass the
Press really angered the Press but
they're addicted to him they're still
addicted to him they're calling it the
Trump slump now because ratings across
the board have been collapsing layoffs
are happening media's falling apart but
now if Trump comes back and runs again
he can directly email everybody
but that is a lot more arduous than a
tweet you've like we get these emails
now everyone's like I guess getting them
from the office of the 45th and I don't
even know how my emails are in that
system but he got him he got my email
and now it's just going direct to my
mailbox but think about this he's not
gonna be able to tweet or go on YouTube
and say anything so the only thing that
will come from Trump is going to be the
like purest distilled version of Trump
without the the nonsensical tweets
calling someone horse face I mean let's
see how parlor or something which he
should he sure should I mean he's got to
be careful about drawing the ire of the
isps be cool to see him start up his own
ISP and social network isn't Mike
Lindell he is yeah I have that article
pulled up actually
my pillow
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell says he is
launching his own social media site in
the next four or five weeks after being
barred from Twitter for election fraud
claims now I'll tell you this Mike
Lindell wasn't just barred from Twitter
what didn't like rsbn was interviewing
he was being interviewed and they turned
his mic off yeah and on Newsmax one of
the anchor stormed off because Mike
Liddell wouldn't stop talking about yeah
the election and you know what you know
like the crazy thing is Man look it's
all due respect Crowder even talked
about the claims Mike Lindell has made
and he's like I'm sorry someone gave him
bad information it's just not true
because like a lot of the stuff Mike
Lindell put out I guess this is what
Crowder was saying some of the counties
where he claimed impropriety happened
don't even use Dominion voting machines
and Crowder confirmed that credit
Crowder did his own investigation where
he found crazy stuff he found that's the
thing though like the mainstream media
pushed the Russia hoax for years yeah
like and we we can't censor them so why
should he be censored even if he's
knowingly putting out false information
which I don't think is the case but even
if he was he has a right to do that
everybody has a right to lie you're it
lying is not illegal well it's still
First Amendment speech it is yep the the
government has outsourced censorship to
corporations it's how you it's how you
it's yeah it's how you destroy the
Constitution so what you see in like uh
it's a scaling problem for sure think
about like the 17 hundreds when you had
you know I guess what did they have
flint lock pistols and muskets and
you're walking around the small town the
buildings aren't very big the population
is not particularly dense but you can be
armed and everybody you know a lot of
people typically were
well until the Redcoat started seizing
people's weapons which you know led to
part of the you know a lot of the
Revolution a lot of the sentiment
towards it but now look at Chicago for
instance ridiculously dense buildings
everywhere massive buildings and on
every building in Chicago there's a sign
with a gun and a you know circle around
it a line going through it you can't
bring weapons in here
so even though you have the right to
bear arms not on private property now I
can respect that if someone's got a
store and they're like I don't want you
to come in here with a gun because we
got to deal with burglars whatever and I
don't know who I was supposed to trust
and I don't want to I don't want to deal
with it that I get you can go to the
next store but what happens when there's
one store what if there was only like
you guys have seen Idiocracy we still
haven't what was it like Costco Costco
there was one Costco I love you yeah
yeah so they show like so it's 500 years
in the future Mike Judge is a genius by
the way and uh they're going to the
store and it's this massive like
multi-square mile Mass you know Costco
and it's just that's the future but what
if that was the only place you could go
to get resources and they wouldn't let
you speak and any say anything or bear
arms the issue is
well if I have to go into this place
like imagine if a private company bought
all of the land in Chicago and then if
you wanted to walk into the city you you
lost all your constitutional rights like
that's the problem because Facebook and
these websites are in Virtual spaces
they're getting away with doing it you
know Republicans weren't smart at the
Republican politicians were too stupid
to do anything about it but I'll tell
you this I think the Republican
politicians for the most part are what's
the right word for it they're like
dangling keys to keep Republicans
distracted who was it who was reading Dr
Seuss recently and Kevin McCarthy Kevin
McCarthy wow very very even read one of
them exactly so brave but think about
this
that's that's what you voted for he's
reading what he's reading one of these
books didn't they ban green eggs in him
no really yeah no that's not like the
most wholesome book yeah okay okay so
that's what he does what was he doing
and and correct me if I'm wrong but uh
or if I'm if I'm out of out of turn and
saying so where was he when they were
tearing down statues where where was he
when across the country where was he
when in Wisconsin black lives matter
rioters tore down a statue of Hans
Christian Hagg a civil war hero who
fought to he was an abolitionist who
fought to end slavery and he gave his
life doing so
where where were these Republicans a few
of them spoke out right absolutely but
look are we gonna sit here and be like
Thomas Massey and Rand Paul are cool
dudes I don't like lumping them in with
like Mitch McConnell yeah yeah they're
very different they're unique yeah he's
great I don't know but I like him he's a
great deal he's one of my favorites yeah
maybe they should start a new party uh
it's sick but then they don't win and so
I certainly think they need to do a new
party but Trump is like we're not going
to do it why it would work if the left
did it too if the left started a
progressive social Democrats thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all
next time